NBA Finals party I need to sign off on
the guest list hey you invite the kit
you say keep it sophisticated why do you
hate fun invite the kid
can I please shave us off no you may not
because your team lost therefore you
have to look like me which one go for
third option
get out all right a run a final check on
the party list question Captain Steve
Rogers too soon
sending invites no way I'm gonna watch
the NBA Finals with mr. stork so you're
gonna let me go nice try buddy
finally here we go do you think here oh
you have bottom and we pick possible
combinations haha I can keep that too
yeah done for me some plays Ernie look
sweet look next mission will call you
alright
it's not a hug defenders grab the top
quick alright there yet
alright good luck out there
hey Peter come tonight I can't tonight I
got the start internship what's up guys
mr. Smurf is my report for tonight I
stopped a glance at bicycle hey could
you do me a favor hold on there's
anybody by oh I helped us little lady
and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just promised I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys on
the real event just hope gives it away
new move them working on the bed
he's working for crazy dangerous mr.
Tator there people who handle this sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
a Canadian parachute
the world's changing boys timely change
to my can't prove myself will use
Spanish Queens you gotta get better at
this part of the job oh-oh-oh
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting younger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because mister
start treating me like a kid could you
are a kid yeah you can stop a boss with
his bare hands
you
you